this program is brought to you by emory
university i am delighted to be here
with you and I thought we might have a
dialogue and discussion and how the
civil rights movement and its impact on
peace and and social change and so I
wanted to first introduce my wife Kate
Lafayette who's here with me native of
Tuskegee Alabama and she actually knew
booker t washington and George
Washington Carver a little girl and dr.
father was Boogedy Washington's office
boy and George Washington cover is to
help her mother you know cultivate our
plants and garden that sort of thing so
she had an unusual experience and also
was one of the first groups and went
down and a lawsuit dealing with border
registration in Macon County group of
college students who were in this court
case to open up the registration for
blacks but more than that she is very
special because I know that God you know
loves me because he sent me an angel to
guide me to heaven
so I know what yes and it's just such a
great pleasure to always be here with it
so what I want to say is this I wanted
to share with you some of the specific
challenges in the civil rights struggle
as we call it I call it the non-violence
movement and that's a difference between
civil rights and non-violence is that
the non-violence is based on not simply
gaining access to your rights but it has
to do with complete transformation of
those who denied you your rights and
being able to create what we call a
beloved community so there's a goal that
extends beyond simply rights as citizens
but it's a community of human beings so
it transcends citizenship and as we deal
with these issues of immigration you
might want to keep in mind that's an
important challenge you know for us who
are here because it was a time when we
were not here and our parents were
immigrants so think in terms of how you
would treat someone else's parents and
children so we want to talk about the
history of the movement we want to
quickly get into domestic issues and
other international conflict and as well
in today's society now I grew up in
tampa florida and ybor city and those
who know ybor city i was born across the
street from the cigar factory there in
tampa
Tampa cigar factories so I was in a
neighborhood that was multicultural so I
ate all the food but I didn't know who
fixed it you know prepared it would you
call it you know whether it was Italian
or whether it was koshka you know our
Jewish food you know how Cuban food all
of it you know West Indian food you know
was all food to me and we would just all
mix it up and eat it okay so that was
very enlightening and there was an
important kind of exposure that had fed
into my interpretation of my community
and therefore affected how I saw myself
and how I began to see others and so it
was was global the person who did our
laundry for example who had the the
laundry there on fourteenth Street was
Chinese my first Barbara was chino
Chinese and his haircuts cost ten cents
in down at the other they charge 25 so I
went to chino he had one style he cut
and that is all of your hair off
so money is time so they didn't take
time to shape up anything you know and
no raisin stuff like that so I've had
the benefit of that kind of exposure so
it had something to do with the way I
saw you know the world humanity but it's
not the experience alone I've come to
discover but it's one's interpretation
of the experiences that's why you have
like I met the other day one of the
inmates and rhode island whose you know
brother is a judge he's inmate so they
are in the same area you know
geographically but different you know
ends of it that kind of thing so what
happened so it's not just simply having
the same experience they have same
grandparents st. parents you know and
uncles and aunts and same minister but
one win one direction the other sorry
account for that you have to say well
it's the interpretation of the
experience that's important so you can't
assume that when children watch
television that they are are going to
come out with the same you know
interpretation why it's so important to
talk to children find out what they're
thinking about what's on their mind and
how they experience in life and
grandparents oh if they have
grandparents or either somebody should
adopt some you know that is full so
important because they're a lot more
patient and they can you know share a
lot deeper experiences and that kind of
thing is too so that's what happened to
me it was my grandmother okay she was my
foster I have to write a book about her
because I think about it all the time
she used to shouts in church on Sundays
we should go to church four times on
Sunday you know all of the services look
at the late night and she was she
carried the money for the baptist
student union and she cared in First
National Bank right down here that's
when she carried the money and a lot of
it was change when the preacher you know
was preaching and he round her up
sometimes she would throw that you know
how could you full of change at him yeah
so she would connect in other words feel
you you know so that's what I grew up
with there and so she organized the
church in our living room 35 people now
it's 3,000 so she was an organizer so
when I went to Harvard University and my
graduate program they had to list all of
the areas of knowledge i had and one of
my cell was organizing protective
organizer with snake and when I got to
the question of where did I learn to
organize which courses that took and I
drew a blank and I had to just tell the
truth that's a grandmama its own
director here are we yeah so anyway
organizing is one of the things that I'm
very keenly interested in excited about
now in the movement I'm going to run a
quick sketch here and then we're talk
some people ask what is what was it that
motivated me and caused me to get
involved and that's why start with
grandmother we were catching a streetcar
in those days they had the trolley you
know down the middle of the street with
the cable cable car and sometimes the
you out we would approach to
run and the receptacle to put our money
in there and then we had a disembark get
off the street car and walk on the
streets back to the rear door of this
streetcar and that's where blacks were
allowed to get on could just walk
through the how and so we had to run and
sometimes the conductor would fold up
the you know close the door and fall off
the steps as long as you keep the door
open the steps wouldn't move so I used
to run ahead of my grandmother and crack
ho to the door until she was able to
make it back there and get on so it
would be moving too fast you know and
this one day we were doing a little
routine and she fell and the middle of
the streets her he loved her she caught
in the cracks of the Copperstone around
the tracks and he I was a little boy 7
years old a region for her reaching for
the door and I felt so helpless so
powerless and they took off with our
money so like you know even if we had to
wait for another streetcar they robbed
us in a sense humiliated us dehumanizing
kind of thing and I felt something to
split me in half like a sword as I try
to reach for the door to keep it open
and reach for her
well I remember saying something that
seven years old to myself and I'm told
later that at age 7 has something in
your life experience that you would
always keep in the back of your memory
and I know it mine and that was that
experience but I said to myself when I
get grown I'm going to do something
about this problem and that was the
first step towards my journey so guess
what a lot of people say well why did
you get involved in this stuff and why'd
you drop out of school and why were you
so passionate wise I wasn't thinking
about my grandchildren cuz I don't have
any of course you know I was thinking
about what it would be life of my
grandmother to have this experience
before she died to be treated with
dignity and self-respect you know and
that sort of thing and that's what I
wanted to see happen that's why could
not come soon enough for me so every
opportunity I had I would jump at it so
sit in to Nashville Freedom Rides the
next year okay we desegregated the movie
theaters and 11 nights of demonstrations
that's before the Freedom Rides actually
and that same year hi in February so we
were fresh off the battlefield so to
speak all right so I did drop out of
school in and became the director of the
voter registration project in Selma
Alabama and as a whole story of how we
developed that process which we can talk
about and then on to Chicago with the
American Friends Service Committee so we
laid the groundwork for the Chicago
movement and we were able then to invite
my brother King
to come in and on to the national
coordinator for the string mobilization
to end the war in Vietnam and that was
the most that was my baptism in dealing
with conflict within organizations I'm
not an expert I'm I'm a spurt but not an
expert we're still spurting okay with
the Southern Christian Leadership
Conference I'm dead nationally yeah so
but then I was the national coordinator
for the poor people's campaign with
Martin Luther King he appointed me there
and finally the last words I had with
murder the king was in Memphis on April
fourth the day of his assassination we
prepared for a press conference and I
was going to go to Washington DC so we
could open up the campaign office for
the Poor People's Campaign and he was
giving me the final tweaking on the news
release that we prepared for that news
conference in Washington and he said
this to me which was a non sequitur and
he said Bernard the next thing we want
to do is to internationalize and
institutionalize non-violence comma five
hours later he was assassinated I
haven't had time to grieve no
because we had to do a funeral we had to
do Memphis we had to do a poor people's
campaign then added go to school and
learn how to install nonviolent
institutes and then I had to go abroad
to try to see if we could do this so
right now we have x 22 centers around
the world three in Palestine one in
Israel that one in South Africa we got
one in we have a prison in Colombia ok
one of the most notorious prisons there
is now a non-violent center where they
bring children but the inmates to teach
non-violence to them because I was
looking for an institution may be of
higher learning but there was several
stories in the mountains for the main
thing who had tenure and they had many
years so and have to worry about anybody
you know transfer it all right so that's
what I do help to establish these
centers right now in Nigeria we are
agreed to train 30,000 militants and
these are we call them freedom fighters
so they don't lose their fight it is
transformed to non-violence another way
mighty and we are excited about the fact
that the government was true to the
promise of providing them with skills
and now they are coming here they're in
Daytona Beach here in Atlanta they're
gonna be coming and once we train them
in non-violence they give their passport
and they get a citizenship back any of
forgiven for their past deeds and that's
where we are you know today and that's
the major project we're working on
I'm thinking that as a result of the
training we just finished in Rhode
Island we had 11 countries represented
and they're going to be many more people
calling upon us and we need all the help
we can get people to go to the training
and be able to help us with that so with
that I want to conclude my remarks and
be I want to be able to say that the the
power of the scriptures really
phenomenal sacred writings Mahatma
Gandhi the row go down the list Dom la
camara from Brazil ok Cesar Chavez we
think about these greats who have made
tremendous contributions in the area of
peace and that tradition I really enjoy
talking the sixth graders because
they're going to be grandparents for the
people who will live in the 22nd century
so I like to get them started thinking
about what they want for their
grandchildren and it's excited I can't
tell you how much and I should also tell
you how happy I am to be here at Emory
we have all kind of support and
resources and people who share the same
vision in the same mission thank you
so when I open up for any questions
discussion okay training program yes ah
this training program was developed by
david jensen and myself is from the
church of brotherhood and we were
chicago and i had started much earlier
from my work but Martin Luther King and
we decided that we need to maybe just
codify this and see how we can be able
to use that in our teachings and
training so there's a level one training
after you have the two-day core it's an
introduction to the concepts and the
level one is preparing people to deliver
these the two day training and then we
have a level two which focuses on
organizing and also mobilizing and so
that as a result of this experience
we've had we're now going to have
another level advanced training for
those and it's going to be about how you
deal with conflict within your
organization I think we get a lot of
people who would be interested in that
they were and also a lot of experience I
my calculation is done if you are a
leader a director or head of any project
dealing with social change six percent
of your time is going to be spent
dealing with the conflicts among the
people who are supposed to
okay so so I don't want you to get burnt
out just schedule okay sixty percent
okay can't do all those things that
you'd plan to do I'm sorry okay you get
somebody else to do it but you know yes
you're going to be dealing with that all
right and so in our training we do that
if you get a doctorate degree or if you
stab lachey center then you get level
three plaque which the meta-gene and
columbia the prison has that plaque as
well okay so what we've done with the
training is that we have Crips and
bloods for example in LA some of the
leaders have gone through there and our
strategy for training is to get those
who have involved in the violence to
become teachers of non-violence so
that's the strategy like in Nigeria most
of our trainers now Nigerians who were
former militants and irony of it is that
they had camps where they teach them you
know how to kill people and sort of
thing the short felt like this was
leaving the camp his name is sheriff I
said sheriff I just want to ask you a
personal question you know no offense
but why is it that they have you okay
with your size we got close enough for
me to talk straight okay you have to be
careful you know time but your little
self like you training all these big
folks and all that
and his own you know dialect he told me
said it's not the size its how many
people you've been killed in the
shortest period of time one of them
could have been testified after the
training he killed a hundred and seventy
people to his count I didn't know how
many got wounded and died later okay
same camp so once we transform the
people then it became a non-violent camp
oh I've changed the camp site okay
because what you do defines the place
not the name of it it's the activity
that goes on okay so that's the
transformation that we're talking about
so we treated not as a tactic or method
we trained in non-violence as a way of
life like one of them said that his wife
really loves us down balance but she
never thought to the training say well
has it you'll your wife loves us
non-violence I don't beat her anymore so
she's in culture shock because she
prepares you know for this beating and
it doesn't happen anymore so
transformation is not just in you know
Civic work as such or civil rights but
it's the person yes
religion in the trainings and how you
like adopted 32 great mmm glad you asked
that question I don't get that question
too often that we put that in the hands
of the constituents or the trainees
rather than us taking the initiative to
have religious expressions so rather
than saying you know we call it king in
non-violence and everyone knows that
King was a you know Baptist preacher
that kind of thing etc but he embraced
okay other religions so he was a black
dick okay and we know that his learn is
teachings that sort of thing that was
not prohibited to embrace another people
so even some groups have devotion before
the training start and if they do you
want to see if there are any other
religions represented like we have Arabs
okay and there you know we have I'm
sorry nah terrible we have people the
Islamic faith okay and they also have a
chance to stand up before the group and
have their expressions and to
participate because in our training we
learn we teach people to accept others
and embrace others who are different
that's one of the basic teachings that
we get across to help people to look at
the things we have in common rather than
making a big you know Kasim kind of
things that are different and of course
people are inspired by their religion
and in terms of this
you know transformation and we've had
people knock on that door why we asleep
three thirty in the morning to confess
Christ and ask for forgiveness for all
the people they have killed okay so um
that's the approach we use in terms of
the different faiths and even the
trainer's that we have do we bring from
here the United States and we have some
from Colombia and something right they
are of different faiths as well we kind
of you know make sure that they have
that opportunity and another issue is is
women some of them are not used to women
okay be taking leadership that's one
thing they have to get used to they want
us training that's who they evaluate
them all right and they got to learn
that information so you don't have to
make an announcement about it just do it
okay so this is that's the approach we
use yes
I just wondering what about the leaders
of countries taking what you do and
applying it leaders of the country so
get here like Iraq
you think there's ever any hope would be
nice if we had laughter gasps relax but
if we just take your approach and apply
it to nations and leaders of Nations
that's where a lot of people are killed
what we call that legitimate killer yes
it's true through this Nigerian
experiment it holds out a lot of promise
for example most of the leaders in
Nigeria prior to this time had been
using the military approach to deal with
the insurgents and those who are
kidnapping people and blowing up oil
started with SH LOL actually okay you
know which was not the government but
she LOL and they realized the government
could not provide protection for their
workers or any kind of security for
their pipelines or their ships because
these Nigerians used to go out in small
boats and kidnap you know take over the
entire ship good night with no radar
they you know you saw it on television a
couple of years ago they kidnapped 25
Filipinos okay and by the way if you
happen to be able to go back and look at
that because I'll CNN some of the same
ones who in their pictured kidnapping
the Filipinos they are now nonviolent
trainers the one that got us fists in
the air with the you know mass over
space okay and some of the others
you can see that so the government saw
what was happening with shale oil
because she'll or then began to hire
these people once they had the
non-violence training they were
convinced that you know they then were
you know looking at life differently and
looking at themselves differently and
start working the government saw this
and started the amnesty program you can
look that up on a computer amnesty
program the president who started it
died after two years in office and then
another President the Vice President
took over for two years and now that
vice president has been elected
president in Nigeria okay so they've
continued this program because they've
seen how it has worked so you have to
make an example and maybe this model and
example of the most populous african
country nigeria and what's happening
with that might be an example so if not
the present leaders of other countries
they're looking at this but they also
look at the people who have adapted that
adopted that nonviolent approach in mass
movements that we've seen like in yemen
and other places and the message is
coming clear that we are in a
revolutionary stage like we were in the
60s because its global all right and
maybe they get the message okay but if
not the people themselves will take over
the training is so essential because
it's not just a method to try to you
know topple the government or top of
dictatorships the question if you have
not changed the system and you know the
system i'm talking about the system of
thought
that is the most critical system that
has to be changed and if that can be
changed then people will look at their
fellow countrymen differently and there
be a hopeful future so I'm optimistic
not just out of imagination but what
I've seen happen and we have problems
here today but you know I I was in jail
november first nineteen sixty one right
here in Atlanta that was the day that
they d civic the ICC ruling when it's
affect interstate commerce commission
that the ruling and people got arrested
in Albany and I we were in Y over the
butter Street why the snake people i was
with nick and he came back and and we
went downtown to the trailer bus station
and they said they didn't know about the
icc rule it so i spent the night in the
Atlanta jail until they got the
information about the ICC ruling okay so
my point is sometimes information comes
you know little slow okay but eventually
they might get it you know that's my
hope I was born literally 12 years to
the day after the clips that we saw to
put this in some perspective and so
literally I represent the inheritance of
this work and so I wanted to spend a few
minutes talking about how do you think
about inheriting this work and what is
it that is special about it to be
applied to issues today and I'm going to
specifically focus on the United States
just have a case example but then
hopefully in the conversation we can
expand a bit Atlanta during this period
did not explode as a city of course you
may have heard this famous phrase the
city too busy to hate which is the best
marketing line in the history of cities
that's not true I was a hit was a city
that had plenty of
hate plenty of animosity plenty of
violence but it was a city that for some
specific reasons never exploded and was
able to with bumps along the way
desegregate its public accommodations
desegregated schools and in fact become
the home for many of the organizations
that in fact were to lead the civil
rights movement including snick and SCLC
and others and there are a few lessons
from Atlanta's history that I think are
worth sharing especially since this
conference is here perhaps the most
important one is that by the time that
the civil rights movement rolled around
in the 60s there were several
generations of educated african-american
people because of the establishment of
Morehouse and Spelman and Atlanta you
and Clark there were since the 1870s
college graduates who had come from
elsewhere and settled in Atlanta and had
taken their education and built
businesses and schools and churches and
civic organizations one that was
mentioned above our street ymca which
literally is serving as a sort of
training ground for activists and for
people who can fund the movement so
atlanta is this place where you have
educated people who also are in some
ways economically empowered even though
desegregation exists there's enough
economic power and enough economic
independence that Atlantic and how's the
leadership and so there's this unique
legacy of education the second is there
is this unique legacy of moral thought
from the famous churches that exists
here of course the most famous of which
of Ebenezer Baptist dr. King's Church
whose father was minister whose
grandfather was minister to weed Street
Baptist to Big Bethel to others there is
a moral fabric and history that exists
that the activists can pull from and can
also use as a trump card to political
and civil actors who are against them
because in some ways most of the people
who are shown in those films as impress
our claiming Christianity as much for
their work
and their oppression as are the
activists for their resistance and so
the moral framework of Atlanta is one
that is quite special the third is a
pragmatism that existed in this city
that is that was quite unique Atlanta if
you know the history the Georgia in 1946
had perhaps the most important decision
legal decision of the civil rights
movement that occurred that early and
that was a Primus keen case and in short
african-americans were excluded from the
Democratic primary from the party
primary and there was a suit brought by
Manning Primus King to allow African
Americans to vote in the primary now the
reason why that was important is because
Republicans could win nothing in the
state it was a one hundred percent
democratic state one party and so if you
won the primary you would win the vote
so if african-americans could vote in
the primary they could influence the
elections he ended up winning was
created this very unique situation where
the Mayor of Atlanta could be elected by
a coalition of liberal whites and
african-american voters it was one of
the only places in the south at that
time in which african-americans are
literally the swing vote and so you
create a situation where the Atlanta
mayor is literally the most progressive
politician in the entire south and this
creates a situation where the political
system now has is bought into some sort
of progress in pragmatism and this was
used to great advantage by everyone who
was in the movement to bring the Atlanta
political establishment into line to
bring pressure and leverage always with
the threat that this person might lose
their job which was a very specific
threat that could be fulfilled so there
was a pragmatism in the political side
there was a pragmatism on the business
sided later always wanted to be
Birmingham wanted to be the biggest city
in the south and figured out very early
on that the bet they were going to make
was one of progressivism and not one of
violence and so every time that the city
got close to violence it retracted from
that line in order to maintain its
business and economic growth now finally
and most importantly I think there was a
system of relationships that exist
did that were exploited for good
throughout this period the largest
Jewish temple was bombed here in 1958 by
the Klan and some of the first people on
the scene after the news got out were
african-american leaders who stood at
the temple doors so that it would not be
ransacked and the touro would not be
taken by looters or by the Klan or by
someone else and this solidified it was
symbolic and it became a cultural myth
of sorts that was true but that there
was this deep alliance between
african-americans and Jews in Atlanta
that relationship combined with the fact
that many of the african-american
ministers were very influential on the
white politicians that the white
business owners were dependent on
African American consumers all of these
relationships were exploited during this
period in very unique ways in very
specific ways which we can talk about if
you're interested that allowed Atlanta
to make it through this period as a very
different place than the rest of the
region and so I think those lessons are
worth keeping in mind when we talk about
situations and they are levers which can
be continued to be exploited now just a
couple of pieces that I want to throw in
the national center for civil human
rights in essence this new organization
is building a facility to one display
the papers of Martin Luther King jr. the
50,000 peace corpus of his writings and
sermons and letters and and such but
it's also a place to link the civil
rights legacy in America to contemporary
human rights issues and to try to use
the civil rights legacy as a jumping-off
point for contemporary human rights and
there are a couple of challenges to try
to do that that I think this group
should keep in mind in their own work
one is that as an inheritor of this
legacy the freedom that exists for
everyone now that I believe did not
exist in this period and as a direct
result of it is the fact that people who
are born after nineteen seventy have the
ability to in the United States in
essence take multiple identities into
the public
space there have been enough social
movements and enough social progress
that someone can bring a gender identity
a religious identity a racial ethnic
identity a sexuality identity of
nationality identity a political
identity and economic identity into the
public discussion and each of those have
frameworks and social movements that are
markers that they can pull from and use
now that is a wonderful thing because it
is real individual freedom it is a very
challenging thing because you have a lot
of different kinds of frameworks that
may be brought in and a lot of different
kinds of markers that may be used by any
individual who's trying to make a social
change happen it also means that one
individual may be majority may be
minority or maybe neither depending on
the cultural context and so that creates
a very different kind of space as
opposed to this period in which in the
South only one identity matter perceived
racial identity it defined everything
that occurred in one's life access to
education access to accommodation access
to neighborhood access to economic
empowerment everything but now as we've
moved forward thankfully people can
bring multiple identities to the table
but it makes talking about something as
large as human rights very complicated
so that's one challenge the second is
the lack I think of a galvanizing
framework one of the wonderful moves
that dr. King made in the movement is
actually in the first half of the I have
a dream speech which is much better than
the second half if anyone cares to read
it oreck listen to it again and that is
that dr. King changes the argument about
African American freedom from one of
constitutionality to one of declaration
of independence it's the same move that
Lincoln makes when he writes the
Emancipation Proclamation constitution
of course is problematic for the United
States because there's so much exclusion
written into it you can't vote because
the gender you can't vote unless you own
land you can't vote because of race you
can't vote all these all of these things
it's an exclusionary document
Declaration of Independence is an
inclusionary one for the most part
Lincoln realized it King realized it it
was a galvanizing framework
but now some of the issues that dr.
Lafayette mentioned immigration and
citizenship marriage equality religious
issues those are ones that are tied up
very in very difficult waste of the
Constitution it makes it very difficult
to have a galvanizing framework there
and there's not one really that is
available for Americans at the moment
the one that could be available and that
some in this room have used successfully
is the universal declaration of human
right there's only one problem with
Americans Universal using the universal
declaration of human rights and that is
they have no idea what it is if they did
they might pull from it because it's
actually pretty useful if you look at it
the second reason it's a challenge is
because Americans are by their culture i
guess i won't say by their genetics but
by their culture are very uncomfortable
with the non-political parts of the UDHR
the cultural and economic rights which
of course have never been adopted by the
US but for an organization like ours
it's trying to talk about contemporary
human rights issues the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights and its
relevance to American social movements
is one that I think provides a lot of
opportunity and finally I will say that
the other interesting challenge and you
mentioned sixth graders who are also my
favorite people if you talk to a sixth
grader and start with a story that
begins once upon a time some people who
were darker skinned could not you
basically see a sleeping sixth grader in
front of you because it is incredibly
difficult for a sixth grader to imagine
a world in which race is an exclusion
because their life thankfully again
because of your work is usually
surrounded by little friends who are
white or black or brown or Asian or
whatever and they cannot imagine a time
in which that was not possible I even
would say that if you did not live
through segregation you can really truly
never know segregation because to live
it was to feel it to study it is simply
to know it here and so a sixth grader
has a very difficult time starting at
the beginning of this story I have found
in our work that is much easier to work
backward
it is much easier to start with today
and the things that they want and the
things that they see that are wrong and
then uncover how there are inspirations
and stories that go backwards into time
and introduce them to social movements
introduce them to dr. King introduced
them to Bernard Lafayette introduce them
to Diane Nash and others working
backwards it also is uncommon if not
impossible to find a sixth grader who
can separate human rights from economics
which is both a positive and a negative
you will find a sixth grader who says
yeah yeah I'm for Human Rights i buy
this thing and they give a dollar to aid
relief in in Africa you know I listen to
Bono and he sings about social stuff and
that's the way that I'm a human rights
freedom fighter that's both good and bad
but i think a comfort with embracing the
fact that central to younger and younger
people's ideas about human rights have
economics and consumerism in them is
something we all simply have to wrestle
with so let me just end by saying that
there are two things that you said that
I want to reemphasize one is that the
distinction between a non-violent
movement at a civil rights movement the
reason why I have spent my time on earth
trying to bring the civil rights
movement to new generations and and i
should say the non-violence movement to
new generations is because it is about
redemption of everyone it is not about
the redemption of a specific people at a
specific time and that lesson is one
that's universal it's one that passes
through gandhi it passes through America
in this period it passes through South
Africa it continues but this notion of
non-violence redeeming us all is one
that is crucial the second that I would
say is the need to dehumanize in order
to oppress it is the consistent and
universal truth across time in my
opinion on how these situations occur
the only way that one person over time
can systematically treat another person
in the ways that we see from the freedom
movements all the way through what we
have seen recently in North
can the Middle East is to dehumanize
each other and so our great battle in
building a more peaceful world is how do
we make ourselves see one another as
more human and that is what my
organization is trying to do that is
what dr. Lafayette is trying to do and
hopefully that is what we all discover
better ways to do so thank you very much
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University